So I'm here with Eber Stuart, Lisa Marciano and Joseph Lee, the host of the This You and Me and Life podcast, and they have their new book, Dreamwise, unlocking the meaning of your dreams. So I really appreciate you guys being here with us. And if you're tuning in from the audio, you may want to check out the video because in the spirit of openness and vulnerability, we're all appearing naked today. Let's really open ourselves to the Dream Maker. And you probably don't want to miss that.
大家好，今天我邀请到了《This You and Me and Life》播客的主持人埃伯·斯图尔特（Eber Stuart）、丽莎·马尔恰诺（Lisa Marciano）和约瑟夫·李（Joseph Lee），他们带来了新书《追梦智慧：解锁你梦境的意义》（Dreamwise, unlocking the meaning of your dreams）。非常感谢你们能来。如果你是通过音频收听的，建议去看看视频，因为为了体现开放和坦诚，我们今天都是赤身裸体出镜的。让我们真正向“造梦者”敞开心扉，你肯定不想错过这个。
I don't know. I think in my case, I definitely want to pass. It's really a horror show. Yeah, it's a great opportunity to engage with some of the, you know, beyond the beautiful and the terrible, you know, especially for myself. Now, we have a reoccurring bit on here where we lie on the audio about what's going on in the video to try and boost that video engagement. So thank you guys so much.
我不知道。我觉得对我来说，我肯定想跳过这一段。这简直是一场恐怖秀。是的，这是一个很好的机会，可以去接触那些超越美好与恐怖的东西，尤其是对我自己而言。我们这里有个惯例，就是会在音频里撒谎说视频里发生了什么，以此来提高视频的互动率。所以非常感谢你们。
I really enjoyed the book. I think I've listened to it four times now. The last one was definitely just because it sounds true. It wouldn't save my place, but it definitely continues to unfold. I mean, there are things that it's like I remember hearing them, but I heard them a different way. And it changed the way that I would work with a client semantically,
我真的很喜欢这本书。我想我已经听了四遍了。最后一遍纯粹是因为它听起来很真实。它没能帮我保存进度，但它确实在不断展开。我的意思是，有些内容我记得我听过，但我这次听出了不同的味道。这改变了我与客户进行语义分析的方式，
or it changed the way that I would work with, metaphor that came up in dreams. But a lot of those metaphors, what's interesting to me about a book like this is, it's about dream, but a lot of those dreams are just the operation of the subcortical brain. And that's very relevant in the way we react to things and the way their body holds you know energy and so it isn't just kind of like oh I
或者改变了我处理梦中隐喻的方式。但很多隐喻，让我觉得这类书有趣的地方在于，它虽然是关于梦的，但很多梦其实是大脑皮层下活动的产物。这与我们对事物的反应方式以及身体储存能量的方式非常相关，所以它不仅仅是说“哦，我
need a dream dictionary you know I don't really believe and sometimes I'll wondering if you're operationalizing some of it in a dream journal and doing associations and looking at symbols and so on Looking at symbols and so on In and like in my own dreams since reading the book, yeah, yeah It's I you know, so one of the things that you need to have dreams is sleep and the past two months Has not been great. I got six hours last night, but before that this is this is TMI But it was like one or two hours There's been a ton of things going on and I've been really wanting to connect but just in the midst of a lot of personal
需要一本梦境词典”。你知道，我不太相信这个。有时我会想，你们是否在梦境日记中将其中一些内容付诸实践，进行联想并观察符号等等。自从读了这本书，我在自己的梦里也开始这样做。是的，你知道，做梦需要睡眠，而过去两个月我的睡眠不太好。昨晚我睡了六个小时，但在此之前——这可能说得太多了——我每天只睡一两个小时。发生了很多事情，我真的很想建立联系，但正处于许多个人
and professional crises So I look forward to it, but I still we you know, I see clients which is always the top priority above anything You know else and a lot of that stuff was relevant and kind of how I engaged with that. I I don't know and I'd be interested to get y'all's take on this But I feel like I have like a really profound dream like every couple months. But there's kind of even with a me your perspective on the kind of like central thing that I think makes this book so unique is the character of the dream maker.
和职业危机之中。所以我很期待，但我仍然……你知道，我还要见客户，这永远是重中之重，高于一切。你知道，很多东西都很相关，也影响了我处理这些问题的方式。我不知道，我很想听听你们的看法。但我感觉每隔几个月我就会做一个非常深刻的梦。但即使如此，从你们的角度来看，我认为这本书最独特的地方在于“造梦者”这个角色。
You're asking people to see a sort of intention, like a dream is being created by an artist or a psychopomp or a guide, you know, kind of all three. And that changes the way you engage with it as something that was made with intention for you to receive. And I was just wondering if you all could tell me a little bit about that framing and how you use it.
你们要求人们看到一种意图，就像梦是由一位艺术家、一位灵魂向导或一位导师创造的，或者说是这三者的结合。这改变了你与梦的互动方式，将其视为一种为了让你接收而带有意图的创作。我只是想知道你们能否跟我讲讲这个框架，以及你们是如何运用它的。
Well, Young at one point said something. I'm going to kind of paraphrase. He said, I have no theory of dreams other than that I believe that they have meaning. And I really love that. And in some sense, maybe that's the spirit in this book as well, although we might extend it and say that our theory of dreams is that they are the attempt of something in you to communicate with you. So, you know, the dream worker Jeremy Taylor says that dreams always come in the interest of healing and wholeness.
嗯，荣格曾经说过一句话，我转述一下。他说：“我没有任何关于梦的理论，除了我相信梦是有意义的。”我真的很喜欢这一点。在某种意义上，这可能也是本书的精神所在，尽管我们可能会延伸一下，说我们的梦境理论是：梦是你内心某种东西试图与你沟通的尝试。所以，你知道，梦境工作者杰里米·泰勒（Jeremy Taylor）说过，梦总是为了疗愈和完整而来的。
And I think that's true. So whatever your dream is, if it's upsetting or bizarre or seemingly forgettable, it was crafted for you to teach you something that some part of you thinks that you need to know. that some part of you thinks that you need to know. Yeah. I also, I like what you just said, Joel, about the character of the dream maker. And in the book, one of the ways that we sort of represent that is that he's like a backseat driver.
我认为这是真的。所以无论你的梦是什么，即使它令人不安、怪异或似乎容易被遗忘，它也是为你精心打造的，旨在教给你一些你内心某部分认为你需要知道的东西。是的。我也喜欢你刚才说的关于“造梦者”角色的观点，乔尔。在书中，我们将其比作“后座司机”。
And he's back there. You know, he's not tapping you on the shoulder all the time, reminding you to stay in your lane. But he's observing all the kinds of things that the driver can't observe. And in particular, he's observing the driver. You know, what kind of music do you play on the radio? Or do you listen to a podcast? Are you honking your horn at other drivers that are maybe cutting you off or something? What are you doing?
他坐在后座。你知道，他不会一直拍你的肩膀提醒你保持在车道上。但他观察着司机无法观察到的各种事情。特别是，他在观察司机。你知道，你在收音机里放什么音乐？或者你是在听播客吗？你是否在对那些可能超车的司机按喇叭？你在做什么？
But this also goes to a bigger Jungian principle about personalizing contents of the unconscious. So you have a feeling that there's this vague thing, I don't know, it's like this or that, and what we wanna do is personalize it, get it into a shape, a color, a character, something that we can really imagine. And so the character of the dream maker is that for us, that there
但这同时也涉及到一个更大的荣格原则，即无意识内容的个性化。所以你有一种感觉，觉得有一个模糊的东西，我不知道，就像这样或那样，而我们想做的是将其个性化，赋予它形状、颜色、角色，一些我们可以真正想象的东西。所以“造梦者”这个角色对我们来说就是这样，即
is a personality, there is a connection that's more than just a vague psychological theory or some kind of energy. No, there's somebody in the back seat. Maybe we could have a conversation. And what does he look like? Or is it a he or is it a she? I'm thinking of the way that my daughter will watch me while I'm driving and pick up all of the meta communication.
存在一个人格，存在一种联系，而不仅仅是一个模糊的心理学理论或某种能量。不，后座上有人。也许我们可以和他对话。他长什么样？是男是女？我想到我女儿在我开车时观察我的方式，她捕捉到了所有的元沟通。
She's seven, that I may not be trying to consciously give off, but she's like, oh, dad, you're angry because you did this or, you know, do you not like the radio or, you know, do you not, you know, there, there's like a somebody kind of watching you who knows you better than, you know, yourself, cause our kids, a lot of times know us better than we know ourselves, you know, survival for them. Yeah. It's kind of a luxury for us. And the dream maker as an image brings that close, you know,
她才七岁，我可能并没有刻意表现出来，但她会说：“哦，爸爸，你生气是因为你做了这个，”或者“你不喜欢收音机吗？”或者“你……”你知道，有一个人一直在观察你，他比你自己更了解你，因为我们的孩子很多时候比我们自己更了解我们，你知道，这对他们来说是生存本能。是的。这对我们来说是一种奢侈。而作为意象的“造梦者”拉近了这种距离，你知道，
just like your daughter was his dad, but dad. And the dream maker is in service to the great enterprise of analytical psychology, which is to fully incarnate all of our potential. That the dream maker represents the intelligence of all that we could be and each night is examining the distance between who you were today and Who you could be in all your fullness and is
就像你女儿说“爸爸，爸爸”。而“造梦者”服务于分析心理学的伟大事业，即充分实现我们所有的潜能。造梦者代表了我们所能成为的一切的智慧，他每晚都在审视你今天的样子和你本可以达到的圆满状态之间的距离，并
commenting on that distance in such a way that we are nudged if the dream is subtle or shoved, if the dream is particularly dynamic, in that direction where we can bloom. And you know, you also talk about setting the intention relating to the journal, not as a journal, but maybe as a piece of art or a ritual piece that's reflective of some part of yourself. There's a lot that is almost like a religious ritual or Western esoteric magic in the way that you talk about setting an intention, engaging with the process. I'm thinking of the part where you were talking about picking
以某种方式评论这种距离，如果梦境是微妙的，我们会被轻推；如果梦境特别生动，我们会被猛推，朝着我们能够绽放的方向前进。而且，你知道，你们还谈到了设定意图，关于日记，不是把它当作日记，而是当作一件艺术品或仪式用品，反映你自己的某一部分。你们谈论设定意图和参与过程的方式，有很多地方几乎就像宗教仪式或西方神秘学。我想到你们谈论挑选
out the journal and making sure that it's not just, you know, a book. Could you say anything about the non-dream elements of dream work and the non-therapy elements of dream work, maybe? Well, I think that the way I think about it is that it's a relationship and it's about cultivating a relationship. Yes. So, and that there's an intention with that, like I'm, whatever that is, I'm going to listen for it, I'm going to try to connect with it.
日记并确保它不仅仅是一本书的那部分。你们能谈谈梦境工作中的非梦境元素和非治疗元素吗？嗯，我认为我的想法是，这是一种关系，是关于培养一种关系。是的。而且其中有一种意图，就像我，无论那是什么，我都要去倾听它，我要试着与它建立联系。
And it can be a little bit like the Western mystery tradition, you know, in that you're trying to kind of cultivate, you know, a dialogue with this other part of yourself. And there are all kinds of different creative techniques for doing that. But ultimately, it's to take your dreams seriously, it's really to take your inner life seriously. And you can do that with ritual, you can certainly do that just with dream work, you can do it in the therapy room, you can do it just between you and you in a journal of some kind. But the basic idea is to cultivate that relationship. Yeah. And, uh, there's a Jungian sort of trope about, uh, the face that you turn to the unconscious is the face the unconscious turns to you. So we, we turn a friendly face and it can start with, you know, I'm going to go to
这可能有点像西方神秘传统，你知道，你在试图培养与你内心另一部分的对话。有各种各样的创造性技巧可以做到这一点。但归根结底，认真对待你的梦，就是真正认真对待你的内心生活。你可以通过仪式来做到这一点，当然也可以通过梦境工作来做到，你可以在治疗室里做到，也可以仅仅在日记中与自己对话。但基本理念是培养那种关系。是的。而且，有一个荣格式的比喻，即你转向无意识的面孔，就是无意识转向你的面孔。所以我们，我们转向一张友好的面孔，它可以从，你知道，我打算去
And it can start with, you know, I'm going to go to XYZ store on Saturday afternoon, because I know they have a great selection of paper goods, of the reaching out and turning a friendly face, of pick out just the right dream journal, it has to have the right color and be the right size and that is what we can do that's our egos reaching out and saying hey I'm turning a friendly face to you and I'm buying you know something special and it's a spiral bound notebook but the I like this cover and I and then bringing it home and putting it on the bedside table. So we do from an ego waking point of view what we can do and we can do that. And then what happens happens.
XYZ商店，因为我知道他们有很棒的纸制品，这种伸出援手并转向一张友好的面孔，挑选一本合适的梦境日记，它必须有合适的颜色和大小，这就是我们能做的，这是我们自我的伸出援手，说：“嘿，我正转向一张友好的面孔，我正在买一些特别的东西。”它是一个螺旋装订的笔记本，但我喜欢这个封面，然后把它带回家放在床头柜上。所以我们从自我清醒的角度做我们能做的事，我们可以做到。然后，该发生的就会发生。
You know you can't create the dream, you can't demand it, but you can set the stage and turn the friendly face to what Lisa just said of I'd like to have a relationship with you. Or as Joan Rivers used to say on all of her TV shows, she'd lean forward and she'd say, can we talk? And that's the invitation. Can we talk? I'm here. I'm listening. When I think of your comment about the relationship between Jungian Dream work and the Western mystery tradition, a couple of ideas come to mind. Diane Fortune, who's kind of the darling of the Western mystery tradition, said something which I think was in her book on the mystical Kabbalah, that the modern Magus needs to treat
你知道你无法创造梦，你无法强求它，但你可以搭建舞台，并像丽莎刚才说的那样，转向一张友好的面孔，说：“我想和你建立关系。”或者像琼·里弗斯（Joan Rivers）在她所有电视节目中所说的那样，她会前倾说：“我们可以谈谈吗？”这就是邀请。我们可以谈谈吗？我在这里。我在听。当我想到你关于荣格梦境工作与西方神秘传统之间关系的评论时，我想到了几个想法。戴安·福琼（Dion Fortune），她是西方神秘传统的宠儿，在她的《神秘卡巴拉》（The Mystical Qabalah）一书中说过，现代魔法师需要将
the magical images as if they are real and independent beings and on the other side understand that those are simply representative images of something that is more mysterious. So we have to have our feet in those two places. For instance, when you were earlier referencing the part of the brain, that's kind of neurobiology of this inner work, that's that scientific foot we have in one place. And then the other, we have to re-enchant the world and also activate that playful side of our imagination by thinking of the dream maker as an actual person that's hovering near us and observing. And we need both of those attitudes in order to hold the work in the right way. Yeah, that's interesting. I'm thinking about the way that a lot of the prehistoric rituals we have to guess at,
魔法意象视为真实且独立的生命，同时在另一方面理解这些仅仅是某种更神秘事物的代表性意象。所以我们必须双脚站在那两个地方。例如，当你之前提到大脑的部分时，那是这种内在工作的神经生物学，那是我们站在一个地方的科学之脚。然后另一方面，我们必须重新给世界施加魔法，并通过将造梦者想象成一个在我们身边徘徊和观察的真实人物，来激活我们想象力中那好玩的一面。我们需要这两种态度，才能以正确的方式进行这项工作。是的，这很有趣。我正在思考我们必须猜测的许多史前仪式的方式，
when we look at things like Ella de Mercia, there's that step of the ritual of taking this thing that is part of me, but then representing it externally as this thing. And then once I mistake this for myself I make the change that I want to make you know whatever that ritual is doing and I reclaim it and pull it back but I have to mistake this thing for the self externally for the ritual to work I mean you have to kind of have absolute projection in order for the symbol to be reclaimed and and and alchemized in an effective way. Beaut said, yeah.
当我们看像米尔恰·伊利亚德（Mircea Eliade）这样的东西时，仪式中有一个步骤，即把这个属于我的东西拿出来，但在外部将其表现为这个东西。然后一旦我误以为这是我自己，我就做出我想做的改变，你知道，无论那个仪式在做什么，我都会收回它并把它拉回来，但我必须在外部将这个东西误认为是自我，仪式才能奏效。我的意思是，你必须有一种绝对的投射，符号才能被收回，并以有效的方式炼金化。说得好，是的。
Wow. Um, yeah. And you know, I'm, I'm thinking like, as y'all are talking, you guys have all done an enormous amount of creative work. I mean, you have a podcast, you have therapy profession. The podcast is very successful and influential. Um, it kind of re-enchanted Jungian stuff in a way that I mean, it isn't, I don't know that it was trying to do the postmodern thing that Hillman was, but I'm kind of I kind of see it as James Hellman, where the Jungian stuff is very analytical, it's very dry. You know, there's like, people that are like memorizing Latin words and talking about alchemy. And then all of a sudden, somebody comes back and they're kind of like, No, it's alive, like, look, and then you know, people under you know, 70 start to like, talk about it on Reddit and things again. And you guys' show kind of did that,
哇。嗯，是的。而且你知道，我在想，当你们在谈话时，你们所有人都做了大量的创造性工作。我的意思是，你们有播客，有治疗职业。这个播客非常成功且有影响力。它以一种某种方式重新给荣格的东西施加了魔法，我的意思是，我不知道它是否在尝试做希尔曼（Hillman）所做的后现代主义的事情，但我有点，我有点把它看作是詹姆斯·希尔曼（James Hillman）式的，荣格的东西非常分析，非常枯燥。你知道，有些人像是在背诵拉丁语单词，谈论炼金术。然后突然间，有人回来了，他们就像是：“不，它是活的，看。”然后你知道，70岁以下的人开始在Reddit上谈论它。你们的节目确实做到了这一点，
or at least I saw that. Because I liked you before anybody did. And I think that a lot of the reclamation, or just the surge in popularity recently, it's not just because it's relevant and timeless, but because you guys kind of put it in a way where people could understand it and it wasn't putting anybody off. But you have a ton of stuff that you do. You know, why do dreams now, personally, but also, you know, culturally, what feels important? I'm thinking about Campbell's quote about, you know, dreams are private myths, myths are public dreams. Was there anything about the state of the world? Was there anything about the arc of your career or life that's overlapped? All three people decided that this was the time for a book on dreams. Was there anything about the state of the world? Was there anything about the arc of your career or life that's
或者至少我看到了。因为在任何人喜欢你们之前我就喜欢你们了。而且我认为最近的很多复兴，或者仅仅是受欢迎程度的激增，不仅仅是因为它相关且永恒，而是因为你们以一种人们能够理解的方式呈现它，而且它没有让任何人感到反感。但你们做了很多事情。你知道，为什么现在要谈论梦？个人层面，以及文化层面，什么感觉很重要？我正在思考坎贝尔（Campbell）关于“梦是私人的神话，神话是公共的梦”的引言。关于世界的状态，关于你们职业或生活的轨迹，有什么重叠吗？三个人都决定现在是写一本关于梦的书的时候了。关于世界的状态，关于你们职业或生活的轨迹，有什么
overlapped? All three people decided that this was the time for a book on dreams to kind of go revisit that tradition. Yeah, that's a that's a great question. I mean, obviously dreams are such a central part of Jung and Jungian psychology. And also, uh, you know for us, I think the book really arose out of our dream school, which is an online program that we have that teaches people how to work with their dreams. And there's lectures and live events and that sort of thing. And we had done the work to craft that. And we're finding that it was really rewarding. And people were reporting that it was valuable.
重叠吗？三个人都决定现在是写一本关于梦的书的时候了，去重温那个传统。是的，这是一个很好的问题。我的意思是，显然梦是荣格和荣格心理学如此核心的一部分。而且，你知道，对我们来说，我认为这本书确实源于我们的“梦境学校”，这是我们拥有的一个在线项目，教人们如何处理他们的梦。有讲座、现场活动等等。我们已经完成了制作这些内容的工作。我们发现它非常有意义。人们报告说它很有价值。
And we said, well, we have all this material, we can sort of put it into a book and make good use out of it. But to the spirit of your question, too, I want to say that, you know, I think dreams have always been a kind of a guideline, a guiding light for me, you know, when I when I feel lost or unsure or disoriented, I look to my dreams and I think we probably all do. And certainly, you know, when you when you look at the state of the world, and there's a lot to be optimistic about, actually, I think that we're so used to all wringing our hands, but in some large sense, you know,
我们说，好吧，我们有所有的材料，我们可以把它整理成一本书，好好利用它。但为了回应你的问题，我也想说，你知道，我认为梦对我来说一直是一种准则，一种指路明灯，你知道，当我感到迷茫、不确定或迷失方向时，我会看向我的梦，我想我们可能都会这样做。当然，你知道，当你审视世界的状态时，有很多值得乐观的地方，实际上，我认为我们太习惯于唉声叹气了，但在某种宏大的意义上，你知道，
we've never been more prosperous and safe than we are now in many ways. So I don't wanna kind of fall in with this general human tendency to think that we're living in the darkest of times ever, cause that's simply not true, but there is a lot of uncertainty and disorientation out there and I do wonder if dreams could be that which Help us find our true north both on an individual level and also on a collective level, you know
在许多方面，我们从未像现在这样繁荣和安全。所以我不想陷入这种普遍的人类倾向，认为我们生活在有史以来最黑暗的时代，因为那根本不是真的，但外面确实有很多不确定性和迷失方向，我确实想知道梦是否能成为帮助我们在个人层面和集体层面找到真正方向的东西，你知道，
a lot of indigenous societies engage in dream sharing. And I wonder about the possibility for some version of that in the current culture. Like, for example, on the podcast, are we engaging in a kind of modern version of dream sharing when we interpret a dream on the podcast? Or are we creating a place tell, you know, when we interpret a dream on the podcast or are we creating a place for people to come together and, and share dreams and can that be nourishing and
许多土著社会都参与梦境分享。我想知道在当前文化中实现某种版本的可能性。例如，在播客上，当我们解释一个梦时，我们是在参与一种现代版的梦境分享吗？或者我们是在创造一个地方，你知道，当我们在播客上解释一个梦时，或者我们是在创造一个让人们聚在一起分享梦的地方，这能起到滋养作用吗？
can that even be a part of what helps us find a new way forward? Yeah. Yeah. I'll chime in of what you know like Lisa, my own experiences with my dreams have just been so powerful. Sometimes puzzling, sometimes companioning, sometimes really really jolting, but having a sense that we all have an inner life and that's just a psychic fact. And Jung says the unconscious has autonomy and it has direction. And we can have more of ourselves. We can always go within. There is more of us. And it is very comforting and reassuring
这甚至能成为帮助我们找到新前进方向的一部分吗？是的。是的。我会附和一下，你知道，就像丽莎一样，我自己的梦境经历非常强大。有时令人困惑，有时是陪伴，有时非常非常令人震惊，但有一种感觉，我们都有内心生活，这只是一个心理事实。荣格说无意识具有自主性和方向性。我们可以拥有更多的自我。我们总是可以向内探索。我们还有更多。而且这非常令人安慰和安心，
to see beneath the ego where we're worried about this and we're anxious about that. And we have to get the oil change in the car and get the kids some new soccer shoes or something, that there is a depth and there is something else to us, in us, with us. Honestly, for me, I just wanna sell it to people. Of don't you know there's more of you? Don't you really, if you really know that in an experiential way, it's just as real as,
看到在自我之下，我们担心这个，焦虑那个。我们必须给车换油，给孩子们买双新足球鞋什么的，还有深度，还有别的东西在里面，在我们之中，与我们同在。老实说，对我来说，我只是想把它卖给人们。难道你不知道你还有更多吗？难道你真的，如果你真的以一种体验的方式知道这一点，它就像，
you know, brushing against a tree, a tree and feeling its bark or falling off a bike or any of those things is you know it, you have more life, you have more self and we have dreams every night. Why not go there? Jung also lived in a time where there was great turbulence and world wars, all kinds of skirmishes going on. And people came to him and they asked him, what should we do? What can one do? And after pondering, he said, the most important thing that we could do in the face of civilization
你知道，触摸一棵树并感受它的树皮，或者从自行车上摔下来，或者任何这些事情一样，你知道它，你有更多的生命，你有更多的自我，我们每晚都会做梦。为什么不去那里呢？荣格也生活在一个动荡不安、世界大战、各种冲突不断的时代。人们来找他，问他：“我们该怎么办？一个人能做什么？”在思考之后，他说，在文明混乱面前，我们能做的最重要的事情就是完善自己，整合我们自己的无意识材料，把每个人内心深处的东西带出来，这需要巨大的能量。所以梦境工作是一种促进已经在自动进行的进化过程的方法。我们所有人都做梦，除非我们有严重的医疗问题，没有快速眼动睡眠，但每个人都做梦。如果一个人采取荣格的观点，即梦是前一天晚上发生的心理事件的产物，而那个心理事件无论你是否记得梦都会发生。我把梦视为药物，所以每晚当我们做梦时，我们都会从造梦者那里得到一小勺药物，它正在推动我们走向这种圆满。梦境工作是获取那种药物并对其进行分析的能力。每次我们回顾梦，每次我们从越来越全面的层面审视它，我们都在吸收更多的药物。我们正在吸收更多的矫正剂，本质上是在推动我们更
in chaos is to work on ourselves, to integrate our own unconscious material, to bring forward what is inside of each person, which takes an enormous amount of energy. So dream work is a way to facilitate an evolutionary process that is already going on by itself. All of us dream, unless we have some terrible medical problem, we don't have REM sleep, but every person dreams. And if who takes Jung's perspective that a dream is an artifact of a psychological event that happened the previous night and that psychological event happens whether or not you remember the dream. I think of dreams as medicine and so each night when we dream, we're getting a little spoonful of medicine from the dream maker that is nudging us along towards this fullness. Dream work is the ability to take that medicine and analyze it. And each time we review the dream, each time we look at it from a more and more comprehensive level, we are drinking in more of the medicine. We're drinking in more of the corrective, which in essence is moving us more
快地走向那个绽放的过程，这比我们仅仅忽略它并顺其自然要快得多。所以，在危机四伏的时代，我们需要内心资源的支持，这种支持也许我们以前可以暂时不需要。但梦境工作可能是我们能要求人们做的最重要的事情，即成长得足够快，以适应一个剧烈变化的世界。是的。而且我想，当你在说话时，丽莎，我在想历史上有一种近视倾向，让人觉得我们生活在末日，情况从未如此糟糕，这有点，我的意思是，这是一个泪之谷。很多这些问题，
quickly towards that blossoming process than would happen if we simply ignored it and went along our natural way. So in times when there is great crisis, we need the support of our inner resources in a way that maybe we could have floated along without for a while. But dream work is probably the most important thing that we could ask people to do, to grow fast enough to accommodate a radically changing world. Yeah. And I think I was thinking as you were talking, Lisa, how there is like kind of a myopic tendency that goes throughout history to feel like we are living in the end times, that it never has been worse than this, which is kind of, I mean, it's a veil of tears. A lot of these problems,
我经常问客户，你知道，指出这个问题。它能追溯到青铜时代吗？你认为它会在你的一生中得到解决吗？也许我们可以找到一种在这里快乐的方法。哦，我喜欢这个。你知道，当黛博拉（Deborah）在说话时，我在想你所说的“你不仅仅是这样”的方式。我在想有多少人打电话说：“我必须给你打电话，因为有人想让我打，但我想要喝酒，或者我想要做这件事。我知道这有后果。我知道我有孩子，我知道无论什么，我知道无论什么。告诉我这个。”我说：“你知道，我相信那是绝对正确的。那是你所想的。但我认为
I ask clients a lot, you know, point to this problem. Does it go back to the Bronze Age? Do you think it will be fixed in your lifetime? Maybe we can find a way to be happy here. Oh, I love that. You know, when Deborah was talking, I was thinking about the way that you had said that there was more to you than this. And I was thinking about how many people call and they say, I have to call you because somebody wants me to, but I want to drink alcohol or I want to do this thing. And I know it has these consequences. I know I have kids, I know whatever, I know whatever. Tell me this. And I'm like, you know, I believe that's absolutely true. And that's what you think. But I think that
你比那更大，以一种你还不知道的方式。”是的。当你问我为什么要来做治疗时，我不会去辩论你的那一部分。我只是会寻找更多的你。我只是会寻找更多的你。那太可爱了。你知道，这直接出自荣格。他说我们不解决问题。我们变得比问题更大。我们超越了它们。是的，我们超越了它们。我们变得更大，有时我通过想象一棵树苗来将其具体化，有人用斧头砍了它，在直径只有四英寸的树干上砍了一个大楔子。就像，“哦，不，”你知道，无论是喝酒的冲动、创伤还是任何
you are also bigger than that in a way that you don't know yet. Yes. When you're asking me why come to therapy, I'm not going to debate that part of you. I'm just going to look for more of you. I'm just going to look for more of you. That's lovely. You know, and that is straight young. He says we don't solve our problems. We get bigger than our problems. We outgrow them. Yeah, we outgrow them. We get bigger and sometimes I literalize it by thinking of a sapling that somebody took an axe to and cut a big wedge out of its trunk that's only four inches in diameter. And it's like, Oh no, you know, whether it might be the urge to drink or trauma or any
一系列事情中的一件，抑郁症，它持续不断，而且很糟糕。如果那棵树长大了，树干有一英尺直径，是的，伤口在比例上就小得多了，而梦是做到这一点的一种方式。这不是唯一的方法，但它是一个重要的方法。不。而且，我认为约瑟夫，当你谈论梦几乎是，或者无意识本身是一种补偿机制，帮助我们理解其他东西时。我在想大脑在200万年来一直是现代的，
one of a number of things, depression, it goes, this goes on and on and it's, and it's awful. If that tree grows and the trunk is a foot in diameter, yeah, the wound is just that much smaller in proportion and dreams are a way to do that. It's not the only way, but it is a big way. No. And, and I think Joseph, when you're talking about almost dreams being, or the unconscious itself is kind of this compensatory mechanism to help us like understand something else. I was thinking about how much like the brain has been modern, you know, modern for 2 million years. a modern for 2 million years, the way that it works, not just culture, but the way that it actually works, changed in response to the technological metaphors that we can draw, you know, the amount of social interactions that we have to be able to keep track of, the amount of objectivity that increases when there's language and writing and all these things. But it's not really biological changes to the brain that drive that, you know. And dreams are
200万年来一直是现代的，它的工作方式，不仅仅是文化，而是它实际工作的方式，为了响应我们可以绘制的技术隐喻而改变，你知道，我们必须能够跟踪的社交互动数量，当有语言、文字和所有这些东西时，客观性增加。但并不是大脑的生物学变化驱动了这一点，你知道。而梦是
kind of the place where that other part lives. I mean, that's kind of a messy image, but I hope it's helpful. I'm always trying to bring anthropology back into therapy, and not just evolutionary anthropology, but I feel like there's so much of that in Jung that connects him with a newer audience that kind of speaks a different language. Yeah, no, I think that's really great. I mean, the idea that there is kind of great wisdom in the subcortical regions. And I don't think that's- It's the point.
那种另一部分居住的地方。我的意思是，那是一个混乱的意象，但我希望它有帮助。我总是试图把人类学带回治疗中，不仅仅是进化人类学，但我感觉荣格中有太多东西将他与一种以不同语言说话的新受众联系起来。是的，不，我认为这真的很棒。我的意思是，皮层下区域存在某种伟大智慧的想法。而且我不认为那是——这是重点。
It's the point. And we don't study it. We don't study it because we can't aim drugs at it. It's like why everyone wants these cognitive theories of schizophrenia, where it's like, everyone wants these these cognitive theories of schizophrenia, or it's like, no, no, it's the indirect pathway. Like it is that one of my friends, Kathy Bird Navisar, who's a Jungian analyst that stopped doing her PhD in neurology work, because they went on to research what she wanted to research, you know, said, the indirect pathway is thinking
这是重点。而且我们不研究它。我们不研究它，因为我们无法用药物针对它。就像为什么每个人都想要这些精神分裂症的认知理论，就像，每个人都想要这些精神分裂症的认知理论，或者就像，不，不，是间接通路。就像它是我的朋友之一，凯西·伯德·纳维萨（Kathy Bird Navisar），一位荣格分析师，她停止了神经学博士学位的研究，因为他们去研究她想研究的东西，你知道，她说，间接通路是在
in these metaphors. And it's supposed to censor out all this physical information and all of this, you know other sort of Semicognitive information and when you have schizophrenia or a dopamine disorder in the family You know if you're not psychotic a lot of times you're a better researcher But if you have too much of it you start to mistake Metaphors for literal reality and there's no filtering mechanism now when I worked with outpatient schizophrenia. I went to this filtering mechanism. Now when I worked with outpatient schizophrenia, I went to this one of the clients I really loved, you know, it was pretty typical, like aluminum foil over the house and the government is coming in and doing these things. And one day I was like, you know, hanging out with them because you know, he, you just kind of sit there and
这些隐喻中思考。它应该审查掉所有这些物理信息和所有这些，你知道其他类型的半认知信息，当你家里有精神分裂症或多巴胺障碍时，你知道，如果你没有精神病，很多时候你是一个更好的研究者。但如果你有太多，你开始把隐喻误认为是字面现实，现在没有过滤机制。当我从事门诊精神分裂症工作时，我去了这个过滤机制。现在当我从事门诊精神分裂症工作时，我去了这个，我非常喜欢的一位客户，你知道，这很典型，比如房子上盖着铝箔，政府进来了，在做这些事情。有一天我就像，你知道，和他们待在一起，因为你知道，他，你只是坐在那里，
talk and he was like, it's like, you know, you used to say that you discovered this online or that you read this book about gang stalking or that now you're you don't have books, you don't have a car, you don't have internet and you're figuring out what the government's doing with satellites. So how are you figuring it out? And he was like, you get the feeling that you have right before you wonder if something's true, but then you just know it's true. It's like that is the best description of the illusion. I mean, fascinating, but it's like, that pathway is still active in everyone, you know, there's still that job to remind the patient that we are, you know, not logical beings that have emotions, we are sometimes we are emotional beings that sometimes have logic and right. Right. You know, yeah. So I don't know, how do you approach these keys in in therapy?
谈话，他说：“就像，你知道，你过去常说你在网上发现了这个，或者你读了这本关于帮派跟踪的书，或者现在你没有书，没有车，没有互联网，你正在弄清楚政府在用卫星做什么。那么你是怎么弄清楚的？”他说：“你有一种感觉，就在你怀疑某事是否真实之前，但随后你就知道它是真的。”就像那是对幻觉最好的描述。我的意思是，迷人，但就像，那个通路在每个人身上仍然活跃，你知道，仍然有那个工作去提醒病人我们是，你知道，不是有情绪的逻辑生物，我们有时是有逻辑的情绪生物，对吧。对。你知道，是的。所以，我不知道，你在治疗中是如何处理这些关键的？
I mean, how do you use them when you're doing analysis? Wow, you know, for me, the way I work is so intuitive. That, that, you know, it's I'm sort of, and I think that's probably true for many of us where I'm just kind of monitoring hopefully closely what's going on in the moment to moment interaction and, and letting my interventions really be led by what's kind of bubbling up from, from the intuitive region. You know, one of, one of the things about this, the book is that, um, that is the way that I know I worked with dreams to was very intuitively, I think that's true for all of us. And one of the things we really wanted to do with the book, because it's such an implicit process when you're, when you're, you know, used to working with dreams. And, you know, it looks, it looks like magic. It looks like this black box, right? Someone tells us a dream and we're like, Oh, I think it's this, this and this. And then people are like, How did you do that? How did you get there? And in some sense, what we wanted to do with the book was try to make those implicit intuitive processes more explicit to give you the ability to work with your own dreams, right?
我的意思是，你在做分析时是如何使用它们的？哇，你知道，对我来说，我工作的方式非常直觉。以至于，你知道，我有点，而且我认为这对我们许多人来说可能都是真的，我只是在监控，希望密切监控当下互动中正在发生的事情，并让我的干预真正由从直觉区域冒出来的东西引导。你知道，关于这本书的一件事是，那是我知道我处理梦的方式，也非常直觉，我认为这对我们所有人来说都是真的。我们真正想用这本书做的一件事，因为当你习惯于处理梦时，这是一个非常隐含的过程。而且，你知道，它看起来，它看起来像魔法。它看起来像这个黑匣子，对吧？有人告诉我们一个梦，我们就像，“哦，我想是这个，这个和这个。”然后人们就像，“你是怎么做到的？你是怎么得到的？”在某种意义上，我们想用这本书做的是尝试使那些隐含的直觉过程更加明确，给你处理自己梦的能力，对吧？
I mean, I always talk about how I work with dreams pretty much every single day, people bring in dreams, we work on dreams on the podcast. I mean, I must, I don't know, work with 10 dreams a week or something every single week. But when I wake up from my own dream, I'm often like, I have no idea, no idea what that means. So I think that there's such a barrier to being able to kind of see the perspective
我的意思是，我总是谈论我几乎每天都处理梦，人们带来梦，我们在播客上处理梦。我的意思是，我必须，我不知道，每周处理10个梦或者类似的东西，每周都是。但当我从自己的梦中醒来时，我经常就像，我不知道，不知道那意味着什么。所以我认为在能够看到无意识的视角方面存在如此大的障碍，
of the unconscious when it's our unconscious that we really need some of the perspective openers that we try to provide in the book when we have these keys. Really, that's what they're meant to do. So the book has these 69 keys in it. And they're basically little prompts that you can apply to your dreams. And they're basically little prompts that you can apply to your dreams. And the purpose really is to pop you out of your conscious standpoint, so that you can maybe begin to see what this other part of you is trying to get at. Central to the idea of the keys is also the idea of differentiation and distinctions, and particularly significant distinctions. So we've all had analysis come in and say, oh, I didn't have a dream. You say, really? You didn't have any dream? They go, oh, yes,
当它是我们的无意识时，我们确实需要我们在书中尝试提供的一些视角开启器，当我们有这些关键时。真的，这就是它们的本意。所以这本书里有69个关键。它们基本上是你可以应用于梦境的小提示。它们基本上是你可以应用于梦境的小提示。而目的确实是让你跳出你的意识立场，这样你也许可以开始看到你内心的这一部分试图达到什么。关键理念的核心也是分化和区别的想法，特别是重要的区别。所以我们都有分析者进来，说：“哦，我没做梦。”你说：“真的？你没做任何梦？”他们说：“哦，是的，
but I had this stupid dream. I was nothing. It was nothing. Then they want it telling you, and it's substantive. There's a lot in it. But I think what happens is that when we look at the dream, or if we're new to this, when we look at the dream as a whole, we often gloss over things. We don't know how to tell ourselves how one thing is different from another. So the questions give us a sense of how to define the parts of dreams, which then gives us a sense of differentiation. So I'm biologically male and so a male figure is more likely to be a shadow figure for me. Just that alone gives us a way to take something and set it aside, coordinate it off and attach it to a particular piece of theory which is relevant for how we then take it back in and
但我做了这个愚蠢的梦。它什么都不是。它什么都不是。”然后他们告诉你，它是实质性的。里面有很多东西。但我认为发生的事情是，当我们看梦时，或者如果我们是新手，当我们看梦时，我们经常掩盖事情。我们不知道如何告诉自己一件事与另一件事有何不同。所以这些问题给了我们一种定义梦境部分的感觉，这反过来给了我们一种分化的感觉。所以我生理上是男性，所以男性形象对我来说更有可能是阴影形象。仅此一点就给了我们一种方法，把某样东西拿出来放在一边，协调它，并把它附着在特定的理论片段上，这与我们随后如何把它收回并
make sense of it as a psychological metaphor. So the 69 keys are also 69 ways to tell one thing apart from another thing. And all forms of mastery are based on how to make significant distinctions between things. If you were cooking and you couldn't tell the difference between sugar and salt because they kind of look the same, it would be difficult to successfully cook. To be able to look at the image and say, oh, this is an Anima image and this is a shadow image in the same way in the kitchen of dream interpretation, it allows me to be more competent. I'd like to put in a word for feeling. We have a chapter in the book on feeling. And out of all the books we all bought and went through and studied and read and tried to process,
把它理解为心理隐喻有关。所以这69个关键也是69种区分一件事和另一件事的方法。所有的精通形式都基于如何对事物进行重要的区分。如果你在做饭，而你无法区分糖和盐，因为它们看起来有点像，那么成功做饭将是困难的。能够看意象并说，“哦，这是阿尼玛（Anima）意象，这是阴影意象”，在梦境解释的厨房里，它让我更有能力。我想为感觉说几句话。我们在书里有一个关于感觉的章节。在我们所有购买、研究、阅读并试图处理的书籍中，
there isn't one in my possession that has a chapter on feeling and dreams. It's as if feeling is a subset that is woven through other more distinguishable seeming topics. But one of the truths about dreams is that they are images of affect. There can be several different kinds of affect in a single dream. Now, first everything was great. I was on the beach and it was warm and sunny. And then I saw this big wave out in the distance and I realized it was a tsunami and I got scared.
我拥有的书里没有一本有关于感觉和梦的章节。就好像感觉是一个子集，编织在其他看起来更可区分的主题中。但关于梦的真理之一是它们是情感的意象。一个梦中可以有几种不同类型的情感。现在，起初一切都很棒。我在海滩上，天气温暖晴朗。然后我看到远处有一个大浪，我意识到那是海啸，我感到害怕。
And then, and then, and then. And to be able to sink into and feel the feeling in an image the feeling in an image is really important. Wait a minute, what part of me, how does that happen to me? That everything looks like it's fine as if I'm on the beach, and then all of a sudden it feels like some sort of dark menacing thing shows up. What is that? But dreams are telling us about our feelings. And I think in our busy lives we often go whizzing past it. People may be anxious and depressed, but we don't let those feelings tell us what they really mean. And dreams give us a chance to do that. There's an image, there's an animal, there's a tree, there's all the hundreds and millions of things that dreams can bring us. And that we can just live with some of that feeling of let yourself feel the feeling. What was that like? I think it's enormously important. The feelings are there anyway. And you know, that takes us straight into
然后，然后，然后。能够沉浸并感受意象中的感觉，意象中的感觉真的很重要。等一下，我内心的哪一部分，那是怎么发生在我身上的？一切看起来都很好，好像我在海滩上，然后突然感觉某种黑暗的威胁性东西出现了。那是什么？但梦正在告诉我们关于我们的感觉。而且我认为在我们忙碌的生活中，我们经常匆匆掠过它。人们可能焦虑和抑郁，但我们不让这些感觉告诉我们它们真正意味着什么。而梦给了我们一个机会来做到这一点。有一个意象，有一只动物，有一棵树，有梦能带给我们的成百上千万种东西。而且我们可以仅仅带着那种感觉生活，让自己感受那种感觉。那是什么感觉？我认为这非常重要。感觉无论如何都在那里。而且你知道，这直接把我们带入了
Jung and there's something from the shadow. And then can you get curious about that? You know, we have a choice. We can either get curious about this stuff and seek to integrate it into consciousness or it'll just rumble around in the underground and be there anyway. And in service to what you were saying, Deb, you know, the dream maker is kind of a novelist. And so, you know, the dream could be read like our own novel.
荣格，而且有来自阴影的东西。然后你能对那个感到好奇吗？你知道，我们有一个选择。我们要么对这些东西感到好奇并寻求将其整合到意识中，要么它无论如何都会在地下隆隆作响并存在。而且为了服务于你所说的，黛博拉，你知道，造梦者有点像小说家。所以，你知道，梦可以像我们自己的小说一样被阅读。
So for instance, you know, I woke up the morning and had coffee and sat there feeling like I was waiting for a tsunami to strike me. And that conveys a feeling. And this sense of universal feeling, because through the metaphor, perhaps anybody could imagine what would it be like to be waiting for a tsunami to come in and strike you or strike your home? That feeling of dread, that feeling of overwhelm, the feeling of inevitability, and so many other things are captured
比如，你知道，我早上醒来喝了咖啡，坐在那儿，感觉就像在等待一场海啸向我袭来。这传达了一种感觉。这是一种普遍的感觉，因为通过这个隐喻，也许任何人都能想象出等待海啸袭来或摧毁你的家园是什么感觉？那种恐惧感、那种被淹没感、那种不可避免感，以及许多其他东西，都被捕捉到了
in these extraordinary images that the dream maker crafts for us and in a way that our soul will particularly respond to, maybe not everyone, but your soul will respond to the images that the dream maker has given you. Yeah. The other thing I just wanted to mention, coming back to this idea of living in a time
在梦境制造者为我们精心打造的这些非凡意象中，并以一种我们的灵魂会特别回应的方式呈现出来，也许不是每个人都会有共鸣，但你的灵魂会对梦境制造者给你的意象做出回应。是的。我只想提到的另一件事，回到这个生活在快速变化和不确定性时代的想法。
of rapid change and uncertainty. And I do think about this, that Iulian, one part of the collected works, I think, talks about working with people that came to him at the end of their lives. They had some kind of a terminal diagnosis and he would do dream work with them. And he remarked on the amount of progress people could make, but also that the dreams almost never commented on their illness or their approaching demise. That the dream maker is still interested in every moment and opportunity of personal growth, secondary to anything that's happening out in the greater world or anything that's happening even in our own bodies.
我确实在思考这一点，尤利安（Iulian），文集的一部分，我想，谈到了与那些在生命尽头找到他的人一起工作。他们患有某种绝症，他会和他们一起做梦境工作。他评论说人们可以取得多大的进步，但也提到梦几乎从不评论他们的疾病或即将到来的死亡。梦境制造者仍然对个人成长的每一个时刻和机会感兴趣，这比世界上正在发生的任何事情，甚至是我们自己身体里正在发生的任何事情都要重要。
So what I've noticed is despite the turbulence going on in the culture, most people's dreams do not reflect that. They're not dreaming about political problems. It's still the dream maker problems. It's still the dream maker, or perhaps humanity at whole, is still interested in the personal evolution of consciousness, regardless of the outer changes of a culture. The dream maker is interested in you, you know, not about which path you should take or what the political situation is or whether you should move to Nebraska or Finland. It's not fortune telling. It's bigger than that. I mean, the culture, the broader society puts people where they are But they still have to deal with that individually. It isn't and I think to mistake that work for messianic stuff is where a lot of people lose the plot when that intuition becomes unconscious and and a lot of people do that a lot of especially male Jungians do that at the end of their life where they start feeling like
所以我注意到的是，尽管文化中存在动荡，但大多数人的梦并没有反映这一点。他们并没有梦见政治问题。这仍然是梦境制造者的问题。这仍然是梦境制造者，或者也许是整个人类，仍然对意识的个人进化感兴趣，而不受文化外部变化的影响。梦境制造者对你感兴趣，你知道，而不是关于你应该走哪条路，或者政治局势如何，或者你是否应该搬到内布拉斯加州或芬兰。这不是算命。它比那更宏大。我的意思是，文化、更广泛的社会把人们放在了他们所在的位置，但他们仍然必须单独处理这个问题。我不认为把那种工作误认为是救世主式的东西是很多人迷失方向的地方，当那种直觉变得无意识时，很多人都会这样做，尤其是男性荣格派学者在他们生命的尽头，他们开始觉得
They have this message to bring to the people in a way that is, I think, kind of, kind of, I like, I want to check that tendency myself, because I fear about, you know, inflation around the trickster archetype. I remember years back, Joseph said on this union life that he was giving a talk at a conference in front of a crowd and he wanted to say curse words into the microphone. And I was like, yeah, you should do that. That's how you, you get the score of who you want to talk to really quickly. It's you get rid of the people that don't have a sense of humor. It's a fight that impulse a lot actually.
他们有一种信息要带给人们，这在某种程度上，我想，有点，有点，我喜欢，我想自己检查这种倾向，因为我担心，你知道，围绕捣蛋鬼原型的通货膨胀。我记得几年前，约瑟夫在《在这个荣格生活》（This Jungian Life）节目中说，他在一次会议上对着人群演讲，他想在麦克风里说脏话。我就说，是的，你应该那样做。这就是你如何快速地了解你想和谁交谈。你摆脱了那些没有幽默感的人。这实际上是一场经常与那种冲动进行的斗争。
So, yeah. I mean, that's, that's something that I want to check. I remember, um, it was like way back kind of 2016 era and I was seeing a whole bunch of young men that were kind of angry and online and I they were probably just seeing me because I was a social worker that was a male and that was rare and they were All you know afraid, you know it all was this kind of right-wing philosophy and and most of them had an absent father and
所以，是的。我的意思是，那是，那是我想检查的事情。我记得，嗯，那是在2016年左右，我看到了很多年轻男性，他们有点愤怒，在网上，我他们可能只是因为我是男性社会工作者才来看我，这很罕见，他们都，你知道，害怕，你知道，这一切都是这种右翼哲学，而且他们大多数人都有一个缺席的父亲，
All of them had a mother that was either kind of unable or unwilling to meet any of their emotional needs growing up and You know this kind of certainty of here's this hierarchy. Here's the system. Here's the people that are good Here's the people they're bad was appealing and then we'd start to do brain spotting and that will make your dreams It will kick your dreams off immediately You know, I did work somatic stuff for a long time and when you do brain spotting that subcortical brain is getting a ton of information in the midbrain over a couple days. One of the things that would happen with homosalivum was that there would be this figure of the anima that would be terrifying because they're getting in touch with their
他们所有人的母亲要么在成长过程中无法，要么不愿意满足他们的任何情感需求。而且你知道，这种确定性，即“这是等级制度，这是系统，这是好人，这是坏人”，很有吸引力。然后我们开始做大脑点位（brain spotting），这会立即启动你的梦。你知道，我做了很长时间的躯体工作，当你做大脑点位时，那个皮层下大脑在几天内会在中脑接收到大量信息。对于同性恋者（homosalivum）来说，会发生的一件事是，会出现一个阿尼玛（anima）形象，这会让人感到恐惧，因为他们正在接触他们的
vulnerability and they're getting in touch with their capacity for a maternal sense and a compassionate sense and authenticity, but those things felt inferior and bad and scary. And so, you know, the monster would be kicking the door open and they're blocking it with stuff. And then finally the door flies open and they shoot it. And then it's a naked woman who looks so sad and she floats away and they're horrified at what they've done. You know, that your capacity for this kind of contra sexual opposite is reaching out to you saying you need me, you're you're not whole. But that that process feels like this attack, you know, on what the ego is, was just such
脆弱性，他们正在接触他们的母性意识、同情心和真实性，但这些东西感觉很低劣、很糟糕、很可怕。所以，你知道，怪物会把门踢开，他们用东西挡住它。然后门终于飞开了，他们开枪射击。然后是一个看起来很悲伤的裸体女人，她飘走了，他们对自己所做的事情感到震惊。你知道，你对这种反性别的对立面的能力正在向你伸出援手，说你需要我，你并不完整。但那个过程感觉就像是对自我（ego）的攻击，你知道，这真是
an interesting thing. And it wasn't, you know, there was no point in talking about politics of those dreams. But politics was probably a lot of the reason why I had, you know, you know, four of those dreams a day, you know, you know four of those dreams a day You know in that period of history but it's but it's interesting too because It's sort of like that mental that mental state that they were in that Psychology gate gives rise to a certain kind of political
一件有趣的事情。而且，你知道，谈论那些梦的政治毫无意义。但政治可能是我在那段历史时期每天有四个那种梦的很大原因，你知道，每天四个那种梦。但它也很有趣，因为它有点像他们所处的心理状态，那种心理学门槛引发了某种政治
Experience I want to say both in the person and perhaps even in the collective. Well, and I think a lot of those kind of tensions that are the microcosm and the macrocosm, you know, a lot of that really personal work you do as a therapist, you are kind of closer to whatever the zeitgeist is or where things are going. Yeah, you're in a position to kind of hear patterns earlier, maybe, than before they're on the news. Yes, I totally, totally get that. It's interesting, because there's a dream in the book that's a little bit like the dream you just told. And we have a ton of sample dreams in the book. And it's the dream about the guy who's, I think, think like eating the flesh of the eye of the Komodo dragon And then the Komodo dragon starts chasing him and then he turns around and it's a woman in a red dress, you know
体验。我想说，无论是在个人身上，还是在集体中。嗯，我认为很多那种作为微观和宏观的张力，你知道，作为治疗师你所做的很多那种非常个人的工作，你更接近时代精神或事物发展的方向。是的，你处于一个比新闻报道更早听到模式的位置。是的，我完全，完全明白这一点。这很有趣，因为书里有一个梦，有点像你刚才说的那个梦。书里有大量的梦境样本。那个梦是关于那个家伙，我想，像是在吃科莫多巨蜥眼睛的肉，然后科莫多巨蜥开始追他，然后他转过身，那是一个穿着红裙子的女人，你知道
Okay, so there's how you've been treating your feeling function Yeah, yeah, that's fascinating and one of the things I think is interesting about how lizards show up in a lot of those dreams is like a lot of that subcortical region of the brain, like if you look at the way lizards evolved, they have a, the lizards and sharks, some sharks have this clear scale that's like a parietal eye and it tells them how to handle their intuition and kind of, you know, what a primitive archetype
好吧，这就是你对待你的感觉功能的方式。是的，是的，这很迷人。我认为关于蜥蜴如何出现在许多梦中很有趣的一点是，大脑中很多那种皮层下区域，就像如果你看蜥蜴进化的方式，它们有一个，蜥蜴和鲨鱼，一些鲨鱼有这种清晰的鳞片，就像顶叶眼，它告诉它们如何处理它们的直觉，以及某种，你知道，什么原始原型
based on the time of year, because it can detect polarization of light. So it knows how much sunlight the sun is shining through. So is it winter? Do I want to eat this thing? Or is it summer? Do I want to get in the water? Do I want to make, you know, it changes the kind of archetype. And as we evolve a bunch of that parietal system that is reacting to color and all this, we lose the physical thing that is putting input into it. But it's still there and it's still thinking. And now it is really affected by hormones instead of visual input. So it's all kind of the
基于一年中的时间，因为它能探测光的偏振。所以它知道太阳照射了多少阳光。所以是冬天吗？我想吃这个东西吗？还是夏天？我想下水吗？我想交配吗？你知道，它改变了原型的种类。随着我们进化出很多对颜色和所有这些做出反应的顶叶系统，我们失去了输入它的物理东西。但它仍然在那里，它仍然在思考。现在它真的受到荷尔蒙而不是视觉输入的影响。所以这一切都是某种
pineal system. And, but there is this kind of like, system of the brain that, you know, used to sense an energy around us, you know, kind of a cosmology that I think is interesting. And lizards do show up in a lot of those dreams. I don't know if that would be the kind of thing you could never prove objectively, but it's kind of a cosmology that I think is interesting. And lizards do show up in a lot of those dreams. I don't know if it's the kind of thing you could never prove objectively, but it's kind of interesting. It's very, very interesting, very provocative. Deborah was talking about the felt sense of dreams. I'm remembering a talk Hillman gave in the 80s where he told like a story and said, you know, like he would tell it, tell it very narratively.
松果体系统。而且，有一种大脑系统，你知道，过去用来感知我们周围的能量，你知道，一种宇宙观，我认为这很有趣。蜥蜴确实出现在很多梦中。我不知道这是否是你永远无法客观证明的那种事情，但这是一种我认为很有趣的宇宙观。蜥蜴确实出现在很多梦中。我不知道这是否是你永远无法客观证明的那种事情，但这很有趣。非常，非常有趣，非常挑衅。黛博拉（Deborah）在谈论梦的感受。我记得希尔曼（Hillman）在80年代的一次演讲，他讲了一个故事，说，你知道，他会讲它，讲得非常有叙事性。
And it would be like, this is not a dream, you know, and, he would tell it, tell it very narratively. And it would be like, this is not a dream, you know, and then he would go back and tell it like it was a revelation. And it was a very felt, you know, experiential language. And he would say, this is a dream. But it would be the same, you know, series of events. Do you guys use semantics at all? Like, do you have people kind of react to the posture they were in in the dream or go into any of that when you do work, how experiential is therapy? I did a lot of that. My first career was as an Alexander Technique teacher, as a movement therapist.
就像，这不是一个梦，你知道，他会讲它，讲得非常有叙事性。就像，这不是一个梦，你知道，然后他会回去，把它讲得像是一个启示。这是一种非常有感觉的，你知道，体验式的语言。他会说，这是一个梦。但这将是同一系列事件。你们用语义学吗？比如，当你们做工作时，你们会让人们对他们在梦中的姿势做出反应，或者进入任何这些吗？治疗有多具体验性？我做了很多。我的第一份职业是亚历山大技巧（Alexander Technique）老师，作为一名运动治疗师。
But much of that has been lost since COVID because most of my clients are now online and I get to see them from their collarbones up. I mean, I'm guessing they have limbs. So I wind up doing something that's a little bit more like brain spawning where as people are telling me a story, particularly in the first couple of analytic sessions,
但自从新冠疫情以来，大部分都丢失了，因为我的大多数客户现在都在网上，我只能看到他们锁骨以上的部分。我的意思是，我猜他们有四肢。所以我最终做了一些更像大脑点位的事情，当人们给我讲故事时，特别是在最初的几次分析会议中，
if they look away and they kind of freeze for a moment and then they come back, I'll have them take that position, move their eyes into that quadrant and hover there to see what kinds of unconscious material might come forward. And that's been very helpful, particularly in the beginning of the work. But I feel very deprived of information and opportunity to observe the unconscious, the parapraxis is what Freud would say, but the unconscious signals from other parts of the body. Yeah. Yeah, but we're adapting. Yeah. Before COVID, I did something that I called somatic trauma mapping, where I would have people talk about the same thing and I would notice what the body did repetitively and then say do this and see what you feel. And when you when you've got this, and especially when you've got somebody on this in their car, you know, they're on like I have people who do tell a therapy well here but I just, the way my brain works that was not able to make that job.
如果他们看向别处，冻结了一会儿，然后又回来，我会让他们保持那个姿势，把眼睛移到那个象限，并在那里盘旋，看看可能会出现什么样的无意识材料。这非常有帮助，特别是在工作的开始阶段。但我感到非常缺乏信息和观察无意识的机会，弗洛伊德会说是“过失”（parapraxis），但还有来自身体其他部位的无意识信号。是的。是的，但我们正在适应。是的。在新冠疫情之前，我做了一些我称之为躯体创伤映射（somatic trauma mapping）的事情，我会让人们谈论同一件事，我会注意到身体重复做了什么，然后说做这个，看看你感觉如何。当你当你得到这个时，特别是当你让某人在车里做这个时，你知道，他们就像，我有在这里做谈话治疗的人，但我只是，我大脑工作的方式，无法完成那个跳跃。
Well, therapy well here, but I just the way my brain works, I was not able to make that jump well. But so the somatic part of dreams is always interesting to me, like there's a ton of people I call it the magician posture, you know, when there's somebody who's so intuitive, but they're not comfortable with direct confrontation, you know, usually they have a lot of anger, you know, you always kind of get this floaty fighters posture, and I'll just stop them talking in the first session and say, sit up, put your chest out, put your thing, get a warrior posture for a second and see what you feel. And they're like, and then immediately like,
嗯，所以梦的躯体部分对我来说总是很有趣，就像有很多人我称之为“魔术师姿势”，你知道，当有人非常直觉，但他们对直接对抗不舒服时，你知道，通常他们有很多愤怒，你知道，你总是会得到这种飘忽不定的战士姿势，我会停止他们说话，在第一次会议中说，坐起来，挺起胸膛，把你的东西，摆出一个战士姿势一秒钟，看看你感觉如何。他们就像，然后立即就像，
oh, I don't like that. Like that, you know, because it feels like I wanna be seen, I have a right to be here. You know, all this stuff that we don't, as an intuitive that is kind of over identified with that and uncomfortable, we wanna kind of read the room and understand everything before we do anything.
哦，我不喜欢那样。像那样，你知道，因为它感觉就像我想被看见，我有权在这里。你知道，所有这些我们不，作为一个过度认同这一点且不舒服的直觉者，我们想在做任何事情之前先阅读房间并理解一切。
There's not a willingness to have any kind of uncertainty. And this is just who I am, take it or leave it. That never was safe. And so much of that people make the connection to their dreams in a way where even if I was kind of talking about symbol and metaphor, I don't know that they would have believed that connection. Sorry, I didn't know how y'all use that.
没有意愿去面对任何不确定性。这就是我，要么接受，要么离开。那从来都不安全。人们以一种方式与他们的梦建立联系，即使我是在谈论符号和隐喻，我不知道他们是否会相信那种联系。抱歉，我不知道你们是怎么用它的。
I think for me, it depends a lot on who I'm working with. And I'm not averse to somebody who's really a thinking type or relatively new to all this stuff, who wants to know about symbol and language and so on. And I sort of image that as being, that it will percolate like coffee being percolated. It'll come down from the frontal cortex and it'll start to percolate its way down into feeling.
我想对我来说，这很大程度上取决于我和谁一起工作。我不反对那些真正是思考型的人，或者对所有这些东西相对陌生的人，他们想知道符号和语言等等。我把那想象成，它会像咖啡被过滤一样渗透。它会从额叶皮层下来，开始渗透到感觉中。
Other times it's really great to have somebody assume that posture or be like that animal in the dream. That the physiology of our bodies will tell us, will tell us things. Or ask somebody just to do a little body scan of, when you were talking about that part of the dream, you're gonna feel something, maybe your shoulders,
其他时候，让某人采取那种姿势或像梦中的那只动物一样真是太棒了。我们身体的生理机能会告诉我们，会告诉我们事情。或者要求某人做一个小的身体扫描，当你谈论梦的那一部分时，你会感觉到什么，也许是你的肩膀，
or just pay attention to where in the body there just might be information for you. body, there just might be information for you. My experience has been that that's part of the art of working in psychotherapy or psychoanalysis and with dreams is what is the pathway in for this person at this time? It might be physiological, it might be emotional, it might be more conceptual,
或者只是注意身体的哪个部位可能对你有信息。身体，可能对你有信息。我的经验是，这是心理治疗或精神分析以及梦境工作艺术的一部分，即对于这个人此时此刻的切入点是什么？它可能是生理上的，可能是情感上的，可能是更概念上的，
it might be any one of a number of things, but any point of entry will do. There's no wrong way or right way. It's just where do you have access to that part of yourself? And another way of leaning into what Deb is saying has to do with typology. Many people know about the Myers-Briggs,
它可能是许多事物中的任何一种，但任何切入点都可以。没有错误的方法或正确的方法。这只是你从哪里获得你那部分自我的访问权限？另一种倾向于黛博拉所说的话与类型学有关。许多人知道迈尔斯-布里格斯（Myers-Briggs），
but they don't realize that Jung was actually the pioneer of typology. And then it was turned into a kind of a standardized test by the Myers-Briggs folks. But when we get our typological profile, the fourth function, which is the least developed of the fourth function can, as Deb said, it can be your thinking, it can be your feeling, it can be your sensing or your intuition. And the deeper, less constructed, more spontaneous messages from the unconscious are going to come in through that function. We have a tendency to over-prioritize how do you feel, where is the emotion in part
但他们没有意识到荣格实际上是类型学的先驱。然后它被迈尔斯-布里格斯的人变成了一种标准化测试。但当我们得到我们的类型学概况时，第四功能，即最不发达的第四功能，正如黛博拉所说，它可以是你的思考，可以是你的感觉，可以是你的感知或你的直觉。来自无意识的更深层、构建更少、更自发的信号将通过该功能进入。我们有一种过度优先考虑“你感觉如何，情绪在哪里”的倾向，部分
because our culture as Americans particularly is not terribly emotionally literate. But emotion is not the only place that unconscious material comes out of and as you were saying you rely very much on sensation. But many people don't realize that thinking also can be a vehicle for unconscious material depending on your typology. I'm an ENFJ, which means my fourth function, my inferior function is thinking. So it's very common that it's my thinking function where unconscious content is going to come forward and that I even graduate gravitate towards stranger more exotic thinking systems like Kabbalah and things
因为我们的文化，特别是作为美国人，在情感上并不是特别有素养。但情感并不是无意识材料出来的唯一地方，正如你所说，你非常依赖感觉。但许多人没有意识到，思考也可以是无意识材料的载体，这取决于你的类型学。我是ENFJ，这意味着我的第四功能，我的劣势功能是思考。所以无意识内容通过我的思考功能出现是非常常见的，我甚至倾向于更奇怪、更异国情调的思考系统，比如卡巴拉（Kabbalah）和类似的东西
like that because it appeals to that unconscious tendency in my own thinking function. So I think that knowing something about the client and particularly if you happen to know their typology or you can encourage them to do it, and particularly if you happen to know their typology or you can encourage them to do it, that fourth function is going to tell you right from the beginning where the unconscious is going to be whispering from. And one of the ways that I think that shows up
因为这吸引了我自己思考功能中的那种无意识倾向。所以我认为了解客户的一些情况，特别是如果你碰巧知道他们的类型学，或者你可以鼓励他们去做，特别是如果你碰巧知道他们的类型学，或者你可以鼓励他们去做，那个第四功能会从一开始就告诉你无意识将从哪里窃窃私语。我认为这表现出来的一种方式
that is missed a lot in people that are more inclined to gravitate towards the emotion of the dream or the narrative Symbols of the dream is architecture. I don't know if you see that much but I mean that was the environment I always stop people and they're like, yeah, but where is this happening? Where's this conversation? Yeah, and it turns into oh is my house because that seems to be what the analyst misses and the patient misses It's like it was my house. It's kind of my house in the 60s actually kind of looked like my grandmother's house There was lime green here, you know, and I would have I was interested for a long time and Kind of the visual application of Jung's theory and you know
在那些更倾向于被梦的情感或梦的叙事符号所吸引的人中经常被错过，那就是建筑。我不知道你是否经常看到这一点，但我的意思是那是环境，我总是阻止人们，他们就像，是的，但这发生在哪里？这次谈话在哪里？是的，它变成了“哦，是我的房子”，因为那似乎是分析师错过的，病人也错过的。就像那是我的房子。实际上是60年代我的房子，看起来有点像我祖母的房子。这里有酸橙绿，你知道，我长期以来一直对荣格理论的视觉应用感兴趣，你知道
Somebody like Steve Jobs who came in and said I want the computer to be like a bicycle for the brain Someone just needs to look at it and know how it the mouse is the point moves and the X closes the window and you don't have to know command prompt and type. This is just you know and with new urbanism movement with architecture it was this attempt to go back and say how do people just relate to space and let's just meet them where they are. Let's find these kind of archetypal modes of being that most people walk to the right when there's a circle. They're not going to it doesn't occur to them to go to the left, why is that? And so I would start to ask clients, what is the building? What did it look like?
像史蒂夫·乔布斯（Steve Jobs）这样的人进来，说我想让电脑像大脑的自行车一样。有人只需要看一眼，就知道鼠标指针移动，X关闭窗口，你不需要知道命令提示符和输入。这只是，你知道，随着新城市主义运动和建筑，这是一种尝试，回去说人们如何与空间建立联系，让我们在他们所在的地方遇见他们。让我们找到这些大多数人在有圆圈时向右走的原型存在模式。他们不会，他们没想到要向左走，为什么会这样？所以我开始问客户，那是什么建筑？它看起来像什么？
And a ton of times they're describing very specific styles of architecture that they have no academic training around. It's like, that's Danish modern. I mean, one person I was even like, you're talking about ink and revival. I showed him a picture of Blade Runner that frankly, right building. I was like, did it look like this? Were these the squares? And he was like, you're talking about ink and revival I showed him a picture of Blade Runner that it frankly right building I was like wow did it look like this were these the squares he was like yeah, that's it
很多时候，他们描述的是非常具体的建筑风格，而他们没有任何学术训练。就像，那是丹麦现代风格。我甚至对一个人说，你在谈论印加复兴（Incan revival）。我给他看了《银翼杀手》（Blade Runner）的照片，坦率地说，那是赖特（Frank Lloyd Wright）的建筑。我当时想，它看起来像这样吗？这些是方块吗？他当时说，你在谈论印加复兴，我给他看了《银翼杀手》的照片，那是赖特建筑，我当时想，哇，它看起来像这样吗？这些是方块吗？他当时说，是的，就是那个
That's like that's ink and revival, you know Another person and they was saying there was a circle on a mask and something and I picked up the actually that the labyrinth On my thing and said did it look like this pattern and he said yeah, that's it, but it was more squished It was like a lime of bean didn't know what a labyrinth was, you know? But that's one of those. Yeah. So those visuals, do you use those much? I mean, I think sometimes that is where people who are more emotional and more inclined to go,
那就像那是印加复兴，你知道。另一个人，他们说面具上有一个圆圈之类的东西，我拿起了实际上是我东西上的迷宫，说它看起来像这种图案吗？他说是的，就是那个，但它更扁。它就像一颗利马豆，不知道什么是迷宫，你知道？但那是其中之一。是的。所以那些视觉效果，你们经常用吗？我的意思是，我认为有时这就是那些更情绪化、更倾向于说，
yeah, it was very kind of minimalist, modern. I think maybe this is about me getting rid of all of the baroque ornamentation and getting out away from my pretensions and just into the real, you know? I don't know. That's what I see. I was curious if y'all encountered, you know You're really talking about sort of paying attention to all this sensory detail in dreams Which is not you know There are dream interpretation schools or schools of working with dreams where it's really about sinking into that
是的，它非常像极简主义、现代风格。我想也许这是关于我摆脱所有巴洛克式的装饰，摆脱我的虚荣，进入真实，你知道？我不知道。这就是我看到的。我很好奇你们是否遇到过，你知道，你真的在谈论那种关注梦中所有这些感官细节，这并不是，你知道，有梦境解释流派或与梦境合作的流派，它们确实是关于沉浸在其中
And and I would say that that hasn't really been a forte in Jungian dream work for the most part. Although, you know, we, we do recommend that that's a really good place to start. We talk about that in the book, just, you know, what did the air feel like? Did you smell anything? What's the quality of the light? You know, is it cold? What are you, what are you, what are the details that you notice, the visual details, the auditory details? I think it's so, it can be difficult because sometimes the details and dreams are so rich, but very difficult to convey. And that's why it can be fascinating if you have any inclination toward this. I don't think you
而且我会说，在荣格梦境工作中，这在很大程度上并不是强项。虽然，你知道，我们，我们确实建议这是一个很好的起点。我们在书里谈到了这一点，只是，你知道，空气感觉如何？你闻到什么了吗？光的质量如何？你知道，冷吗？你，你，你注意到的细节是什么，视觉细节，听觉细节？我认为这太，这可能很困难，因为有时梦中的细节太丰富了，但很难传达。这就是为什么如果你有任何倾向于此的倾向，它可能会很迷人。我不认为你
have to be a talented artist, but a lot of people draw their dreams. That's something that we're going to be playing around with a bit more in dream school is creating a specific space for people to engage and drawing their dreams and using drawing the dream both as a tool to help recall dreams but also as a way to deepen into the experience. But it's, you know, to me, it's fascinating because some of the, the things that I might experience, whether it's a feeling or a sound or a visual in a dream is so rich and luminous, but like, absolutely defies my ability to put it into words. Bill, when you were speaking, I was thinking about how the
必须是一位有才华的艺术家，但很多人会画出他们的梦。这是我们在梦境学校（dream school）中会更多地尝试的事情，即为人们创造一个特定的空间来参与并画出他们的梦，并使用画梦既作为帮助回忆梦的工具，也作为深入体验的一种方式。但是，你知道，对我来说，这很迷人，因为我可能在梦中体验到的一些东西，无论是感觉、声音还是视觉，都如此丰富和明亮，但就像，绝对超出了我用语言表达的能力。比尔（Bill），当你说话时，我在想
unconscious and the dream maker becomes incrementally aware of the analyst or the therapist. So once the unconscious understands that the therapist is their ally, the dreams are both in service to the dreamer and in service to the therapist or analyst in facilitating the individuation process. So I'm imagining that as your clients understand that you can interpret these architectural nuances in the settings of their dreams, their dream maker is more likely to send signals through those differentiations because it knows that you particularly will pick them up. That's a great point.
无意识和梦境制造者如何逐渐意识到分析师或治疗师。所以一旦无意识理解了治疗师是他们的盟友，梦境既服务于做梦者，也服务于治疗师或分析师，以促进个体化过程。所以我设想，当你的客户理解你可以解释他们梦境设置中的这些建筑细微差别时，他们的梦境制造者更有可能通过这些差异发送信号，因为它知道你特别会捕捉到它们。这是一个很好的观点。
Yeah, I, is there, what about color? You work with color much or do you feel like any of that? As I do emotional transformation therapy, which Dr. Vasquez out of Texas does, which there's these machines that do very specific colors, frequencies, direction of light on the pupil and also a flicker rate, which is kind of wild.
是的，我，有什么关于颜色的吗？你经常使用颜色吗，或者你觉得其中任何一个？我做情感转化疗法（Emotional Transformation Therapy），这是德克萨斯州的瓦斯奎兹（Vasquez）博士做的，有这些机器可以对瞳孔进行非常具体的颜色、频率、光的方向，还有闪烁率，这有点疯狂。
Like with the light device, you can't really see a flicker rate above about 150, 200, just people can't perceive it. But you'll move, you know, the color is just green for the person, but you'll move from 300 to 600, it hurts and the person's like, Oh, my chest is on fire. And you move back, and then it stops, but they don't know that I changed anything. I mean, they can't see the computer. And so so much of that is interesting. And color shows up as a metaphor a lot of the time, or just an association that we remember.
就像用光设备，你无法真正看到超过150、200的闪烁率，人们无法感知它。但你会移动，你知道，颜色对那个人来说只是绿色，但你会从300移动到600，它会痛，那个人就像，哦，我的胸口着火了。然后你移回去，然后它就停止了，但他们不知道我改变了任何东西。我的意思是，他们看不到电脑。所以其中很多都很有趣。颜色很多时候表现为隐喻，或者只是我们记得的联想。
But I also think there are, ETT has convinced me, because my patients don't know those associations. Before we're doing the work, that there are pretty endogenous ways that we handle it that are universal too. So I didn't know, there's not a ton about color in the book. I know, just curious if you see that in your work. I'm not familiar with this method that you were talking about,
但我还认为，ETT说服了我，因为我的病人在做工作之前不知道那些联想，我们处理它的方式是非常内源性的，也是普遍的。所以我不知道，书里关于颜色的内容不多。我知道，只是好奇你在工作中是否看到了这一点。我不熟悉你谈论的这种方法，
although I'd like to hear more about it. Yeah, it's really interesting. Really, really interesting. Von Franz wrote extensively about color symbolism and number symbolism. But you're right, that wasn't something that we have a tendency to go into too deeply. For myself, I don't always think to ask the color of each object, but it's interesting to have that brought to my attention through our conversation here with you. But if somebody does in their description mention the colors of things that of course rings and then we do have a tendency to go into it in that regard. But you're right, it is something that could be flushed out in terms of clarifying questions. What was the color of this and what was the color of that? So my background with color is a little bit more from the Western mystery tradition and I have some thoughts about colors and the various correspondences that they have. That is a bit systemized. I don't know that it's individual enough to be able to apply.
虽然我想听听更多关于它的信息。是的，这真的很有趣。真的，真的很有趣。冯·弗兰兹（Von Franz）广泛地写了关于颜色象征主义和数字象征主义的文章。但你是对的，那不是我们倾向于深入研究的东西。对我自己来说，我并不总是想到要问每个物体的颜色，但通过我们在这里与你的谈话，引起我的注意是很有趣的。但如果有人在描述中提到了事物的颜色，那当然会引起共鸣，然后我们确实倾向于在这方面深入研究。但你是对的，这确实是可以从澄清问题的角度来充实的东西。这个的颜色是什么，那个的颜色是什么？所以我的颜色背景更多来自西方神秘传统，我对颜色以及它们所具有的各种对应关系有一些想法。那是有点系统化的。我不知道它是否足够个体化，能够应用。
Yeah and why 69 keys? Where I land on that? That was kind of what... It just turned out that way. Yeah, the amount of keys there were. That's right. Strictly a bottom-up process rather than let's settle on a number first and fit it all into this box. This was the number needed and that's how it came out. Well, I think that y'all's book is probably one of the best that I found jumping into starting to use Dreams from somebody who doesn't have a lot of experience there or their therapist mentioned it to them and they want to know how to use it as a therapist. Now our audience is split 50-50 about therapists and then patients in therapy that end up, you know, listening to something or getting a resource.
是的，为什么是69个键？我怎么得出这个结论的？那有点像……它就是那样。是的，键的数量。没错。严格来说是一个自下而上的过程，而不是先确定一个数字并把它塞进这个盒子里。这是所需的数字，这就是它的结果。嗯，我认为你们的书可能是我发现的最好的书之一，适合那些没有太多经验的人开始使用梦，或者他们的治疗师向他们提到了这一点，他们想知道如何作为治疗师使用它。现在我们的听众中有一半是治疗师，另一半是治疗中的病人，他们最终，你知道，听到了什么或得到了资源。
So it's, you know, either way, I mean, I think that's probably one of the better places to start. Is there anything that I missed? I want to be respectful of you guys's time Is there anything that you feel like is not was not talked about that's an important element you'd like to speak on, you know It's a lead-up. I'd like to throw in the word adventure And invite people to be curious and to have an inner adventure People spend all kinds of money on vacations
所以，你知道，无论哪种方式，我的意思是，我认为这可能是最好的起点之一。有什么我错过的吗？我想尊重你们的时间。有什么你们觉得没有谈到，是一个重要的元素，你们想谈谈的吗，你知道，这是一个引导。我想加入“冒险”这个词，并邀请人们保持好奇心，进行一次内在的冒险。人们花各种钱去度假
and travel and all that stuff and it's all great, but there is an inner adventure awaiting you. And I think our book can be very helpful about how to get in the water, so to speak, and have something meaningful, interesting, enlivening, and feel yourself growing, expanding. Yeah. What comes to me as I'm asking that question, asking inward and upward, that Jung had a feeling, a vision and an intuition
和旅行以及所有这些东西，这都很好，但有一场内在的冒险在等着你。我认为我们的书在如何“下水”（so to speak）以及获得有意义、有趣、充满活力并感受到自己的成长、扩展方面非常有帮助。是的。当我问那个问题时，向内和向上问，荣格有一种感觉、愿景和直觉
that the old paradigm of religion religion 100 years ago, a thousand years ago, had served a civilized purpose, that it moved something along in the collective psyche. But that the reason religion has been losing its potency in the collective is that we need a new way for the individual to connect to the universal or the transcendent. And that it would need to be something that was highly individual to each person. And that the revelations around how you as a person and that the revelations around how you as a person can and are connecting to the transcendent is happening through the symbols of your dreams. So I think that dreams are also helping us
即100年前、1000年前的旧宗教范式，已经服务于文明目的，它在集体心理中推动了一些东西。但宗教在集体中失去效力的原因是，我们需要一种新的方式让个人与普遍或超越的东西连接。而且它需要是每个人高度个体化的东西。关于你作为一个人的启示，以及关于你作为一个人的启示，即你如何以及正在通过你梦中的符号与超越的东西连接，正在发生。所以我认为梦也在帮助我们
forge a new way of connecting to the transcendent. In Jung's writings on the future of Christianity, he had an idea that they would come a time when people in a community would come together and through dreams and active imagination, they would collectively share how they are connecting with the transcendent and in the storytelling of the community, they would forge an understanding of the divine, of the transcendent, and that would become an ever-evolving narrative. And the sharing of those dreams would be almost something like a Pentecostal experience, where something would be constellated through the sharing of that material.
锻造一种连接超越的新方式。在荣格关于基督教未来的著作中，他有一个想法，即会有一天，社区中的人们会聚在一起，通过梦和主动想象，他们会集体分享他们是如何与超越的东西连接的，在社区的故事讲述中，他们会锻造对神圣的、超越的理解，那将成为一个不断进化的叙事。而那些梦的分享几乎就像一种五旬节式的体验，通过分享那些材料，一些东西会被星群化（constellated）。
So I think there is a profound evolutionary process that is happening both in the individual and in the collective. And attention to dreams is an essential part of that in as much as the collective is reimagining human civilization always, but particularly at this time. Jung said that a new religion is brewing in the collective psyche and it would take a couple of hundred years before it resurfaced in its fullness, but that it would emerge through collective dreaming. And I find that intensely interesting. And I'm paying attention to any of those signals in my own dreams, in the dreams of my Nalasans, as well as the dreams that people submit to us on the podcast, that there's a new relationship
所以我认为有一个深刻的进化过程正在个人和集体中发生。对梦的关注是其中的一个重要部分，因为集体总是在重新想象人类文明，特别是在这个时候。荣格说，一种新的宗教正在集体心理中酝酿，需要几百年才能完全浮出水面，但它会通过集体做梦出现。我发现这非常有趣。我正在关注我自己的梦、我的分析对象（Nalasans）的梦，以及人们在播客上提交给我们的梦中的任何信号，即有一种新的关系
that's being forged between the individual and the divine, which is both capable of saving us, but also creating great and interesting transformative demands upon humanity. Well, that's a great reason to pay attention to your dreams. And I think that that metacognition that is happening in all the depth models of therapy that I think are good, a lot of the post Jungian experiential stuff, voice dialogue, process oriented therapy, AEDP, lifespan integration, you know, any of those, what you're doing is you're finding this way to relate to the subcortical, there's a metacognition, there's a way of relating to the subcortical brain without being possessed by it. And kind of endless intellectual, very purely intellectual analysis doesn't ever really teach you anything. It makes you feel this pseudo certainty
正在个人与神圣之间锻造，这既有拯救我们的能力，也会对人类产生巨大而有趣的变革性要求。嗯，这是一个关注你梦境的好理由。我认为在所有我认为好的深度治疗模型中发生的元认知，很多后荣格派的体验式东西，声音对话、过程导向治疗、AEDP、生命历程整合，你知道，任何这些，你所做的是你正在找到这种与皮层下大脑相关联的方式，有一种元认知，有一种与皮层下大脑相关联而不被它占据的方式。而那种无休止的、非常纯粹的智力分析从来没有真正教给你任何东西。它让你感到这种伪确定性
or pseudo control. But there has to be this being able to connect with it without being possessed by it. And as the individual is trying to do that in dream work, I mean, I think the culture is also trying to do that with parts of our humanity that we can't repress, but we also can't completely go into. And that is kind of the broader conversation that's happening in metamodernism that looks a lot like a collective tension of the opposites and this oscillation, you know, that we're trying to figure out how do we do that, you know. So it's a beautiful, it's a beautiful book and, you know, always try and connect the micro with the macro, you know. Well, thank you. Thank you so much for having us on.
或伪控制。但必须能够与它连接而不被它占据。当个人试图在梦境工作中做到这一点时，我的意思是，我认为文化也在试图用我们无法压抑但我们也无法完全进入的人性部分来做到这一点。这就是元现代主义（metamodernism）中正在发生的更广泛的对话，看起来很像对立面的集体张力，以及这种振荡，你知道，我们正在试图弄清楚我们如何做到这一点，你知道。所以这是一本美丽的，美丽的，书，而且，你知道，总是试图连接微观和宏观，你知道。嗯，谢谢。非常感谢你们邀请我们。
Yeah. Love talking to you. This has been so rich. Yeah. So where can we go to get the book? Amazon and Sounds True for the audible and then also this You Can Get In Life website, which we'll link to all of that is Dream School if we want a more personal. That's right. That's right. Yeah, you can get it wherever books are sold basically. So whether that's bookshop.org or Barnes and Noble or Amazon or the Sounds True website. Yeah. Well, thank you so much. I really appreciate you guys' time and I hope this connects a lot of people with your work. Thank you. Thank you too. It is so pure I can't arrive without the fear I see in my eyes There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
是的。很高兴和你交谈。这太丰富了。是的。那么我们去哪里买这本书？亚马逊和Sounds True的音频版，还有这个“You Can Get In Life”网站，我们会链接到所有这些，如果是更个人的话，就是梦境学校。没错。没错。是的，你基本上可以在任何卖书的地方买到它。所以无论是bookshop.org还是巴诺书店（Barnes and Noble）或亚马逊或Sounds True网站。是的。嗯，非常感谢。我真的很感谢你们的时间，我希望这能让很多人与你们的工作建立联系。谢谢。也谢谢你。它是如此纯粹，我无法在没有恐惧的情况下到达，我在我的眼中看到。这个剧集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。